how about Red Robin do we have a
birthday here yes II have a birthday
here who buys the bird dance I don't
think that's a white guy in your life
yeah bro you got that Dallas buyers club
vibe going this morning you don't kind
of chase fresh
dude I'm paying huh I'm paying homage to
our home egde to UM Western America I
was looking at Western America on a map
yesterday uh different territories we
look up some of the territories of
Western America please net and you're
just doing some research on it yeah now
is that a proper cowboy hat it kind of
looks like you got that from some like
like like black-eyed peas I'm sure what
is it what is black IP do you that did
you get you buy hat at Texas Roadhouse
well this seems off that day like
something gives a man cakes and bread
things - OH
whose birthday is it birthday sneaking
my but Texas Roadhouse man it was my
thing shows got knocked up by one of the
managers hitter retire early classic the
managers just creeping on the way just
oh wow that's every place the manager to
say yeah to make sure our yeah you need
some extra hours how about a 12:00 a.m.
to 2 a.m.
overtime on these nights do you ever
work in a restaurant yes
no never was for the podcast job I
worked at an apartment complex and my
manager was gay so oh yeah Kalyn said he
realized he was old when he walked by
some construction workers and nobody
looked at him I was like well maybe
they're not gay he's like but they were
usually whistle are you at the Abbey and
WeHo I don't think those guys are really
doing construction dude yeah those
dancers dance is trying to build a
bridge in your mouth
trying to build that be how do your
penis you think beef or what kind of
meat is in there if you had to thank
pork you think yes Poli is pork on like
if you had to have a little bit of penis
or something in another country I
wouldn't need any penis here but uh it's
illegal here there you go is it yeah
pretty sure yeah Peru I think you can
add each penis what do you know snuck a
couple of plugin [ __ ] nuggets in a
satchel for lunch
the me exotic Korean barbecues Jenny
yeah how exotic is it get exotic we're
talking here Playboy I bet if they did
to eat penises it'd probably be
somewhere in China like the Han type of
area yeah man what's gonna happen I
guess we can't go we we're not I mean
this is all from China and everything's
from China what are we even gonna have
here we're gonna have to make our own
stuff again yeah yeah I agree
good you just seen Chappelle [ __ ]
rapping that Paul wall this week really
paul wall liked it too huh yeah did he
yeah the People's Champ oh you can get
one man didn't you see him going hard on
the paint is it Justin Lawson no this
Malik Malik Malik I don't know why you
only become analogous deviling Malik is
devil named Bell okay
Malik I'm Mordecai Mordecai really a
Satan boy
jiae's look at paul water looking
comments and eggs
[Music]
20 next Paul cross it's black on the
outside different on the end said I
don't know if I've ever been really
looked so many jams yeah I'm not like
you big matchbox fan rock Thomas
mastered that haircut - man he's one of
a kind
no matchbox 20 in bed yeah it's wedding
oh yeah you'll know it's kind of like
late nineties wedding music you know
showed up at our Phoenix show the the
Chappelle lacy of country there is rock
no way yeah look at what and I told my
joking at 8:00 [ __ ] in front everyone
hey man
dolphins make me cry - no you did on
stage you said hurt his back say
backstage oh my bad yeah nobody killed
us today you went like this what oh what
the Dolphins that they're never good hey
man so Wow I didn't know who he was
really yeah I was like dude hooting the
Blowfish she's like now I'm like dude
get maggin wielded no clue no clue so
many hits man all right this for so long
country fan
he's amazing made from Augusta Georgia I
think some of your line of South
Carolina southern state of mind about
your beast what was he doing there just
a fan died what he was crunk - was he
yeah and was he with a hoozy with
friends or anything just some friends
Wow he lives there he's just where
they're working or what did he say
anything
he'd say things I came to the show man
huge fan yeah I don't think human Brian
knew who each other were yeah yeah Wow
yeah Brian's like who are you he's like
who are you him people got mad cuz we
didn't realize this guy actually we
loved this guy song Jimmy Hutchins I
know Dan Lucille and he was all about
that sick ZZ Top yeah and he was
actually covering wagon wheel which is
Darius Rucker covered from Old Crow
Medicine we're retiring little brows I
got roasted when I suggested that today
we are gonna laugh we're gonna retire
but we'll put it on sabbatical for a
week bro yeah let's take mr. Lucille on
the way out oh yeah yeah it was
beautiful
oh I met Brendan at 240 you did I met
him at 240 dude these [ __ ] guys
losing weight huh kind of dang with
these dudes man
I'm in the back just try and get my mind
right to do my show and how long does
that take they go oh it's wrestle Friday
like I don't want to wrestle
it's wrestle Friday then one starts
talking [ __ ] and then and then this what
happens oh I thought this is something
from a black lives matter rally Brandon
yeah Chappelle tap himself I have no
idea what's going on don't have to tell
me I thought I hurt you cheek truck
driver did you beat the cheeks out of
that boy
dude that Keith Peterson right there
there's too much oh that's no nonsense
Jay
tap yourself I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on bro do not let CNN get
ahold of air be over look at that you
look like a criminal huh
my mana is neck I get a beanie on it's
just a nightmare for me it's a PR
nightmare this is like the damn judge
dusty Smollett Olympics no they asked
for this man I was minding my own and
right before this was another black guy
yeah yeah look man it looked like you
guys you win a good eight seven seconds
if you're a rodeo you'd have done well
you just needed another four minutes and
52 seconds man it's five-minute rounds
[Laughter]
yeah a lot of Western places I just want
to pay homage to what do we have
Idaho Boise places people don't think
about Boise Lorado a Mario is that shirt
very Western yeah do you from ever come
in [ __ ] I wish that was funny
I'm his snitch this is the new of
Takashi six nine no that's that Texas
Roadhouse collection good money for you
to come and do that for people's beat my
sister used to work there so when it was
your birthday right
they used to bring this saddle out from
the back it was like this little saddle
that they had set on top of to baby
chairs you know they taking those little
baby high chairs and they put a saddle
on top of two of them and bring it out
then they would sit you on the side all
and say that's the saddle was sticky to
me my kooky birthday
do we have the bird dance I don't think
that's the white guy in that suit very
got real eggs I can't believe somebody I
wonder if anybody's ever shot somebody's
singing on that birthday song cuz that
gets intense man if you don't want it
and they come do oh it's the worst I
think they stopped doing it most places
though like even Chili's used to do it
yeah yeah yeah for my birthday my big
deal was I get a full rack of ribs and a
chocolate shake come around sing to me
[Laughter]
all this heartbreak in it well yeah
whatever you know life sounds beater oh
man it's got to be hectic when you got
to take your son for a full rack of ribs
$25 meals son that's a good call no
wrong you I seven please after all I
guess oh yeah they bleached up of
officers milkshake Shake Shack following
up good PR last week with really bad PR
they supposedly poisoned some another
milk shaking incident that's what made
me think of it but stay away from the
milkshakes a milkshake brings all the
boys to the hospice kill these dudes
[Laughter]
just healthy yeah that's a thing I get
nervous about having them this is so
thick yeah and I just get embarrassed so
I'm trying to get it out the straw I
can't no you suck sometimes I'll go in
the bathroom and do it in one of the
slow
you know the movies who hearts to know
the movies the long game along it waded
out dog waited out let me I can't either
so I suck I deep throat that strongness
ha ha ha why do you put it off there's
no reason to deep throat it just so
aggressive yeah but just don't do that
just just just suck on it
that's crazy do some guys know sticks
like the boba straws yeah I'll think
those thick boba straws yeah see an
exhaust yeah you should put your whole
mouth round thing Go Daddy
yeah but less of a reason up you like to
suck on it I would yeah I think they
give me a wrong straw they give me like
one of those coffee stirrer oh oh I'd
have somebody yeah I remember kind of
starting to dark out a little just
[ __ ] to my eyes ma'am oh I look
hydrated huh do you look super hydrated
I need to be hydrate cuz I drink a lot
of whiskey on the road dude and I get
dehydrated oh wait I'll tell you exactly
what to do to recover because I've seen
you putting that IV in your arm I know
that's what I do you have expensive bro
and to come on or bucks man
ranch you can get the same effect by
going liquid IV what you talking about
go straight into your gullet man your
favorite hole in your body is your mouth
brother and I know that so what I'm
saying is one stick of liquid IV you mix
it into 16 ounces of water hydrates you
way more faster and more efficiently
than water alone and there's some
vitamins in anytime about vitamin C b3
b5 b6 b12 bombers in your mouth behave
bro it's so good try liquid IV it's the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated more vitamin C than an orange
as much potassium as a banana vitamins
beef b3 b5 b6 and b12 thankfully there's
liquor at IV so I don't have to get a
straight IV and get poked all the
goddamn time the fastest most efficient
way to stay hydrated it's healthier than
sugary sport drink a lot of time you get
a sport drink and they got a chunk of
sugar in there they got a damn you know
pecan coated corn dog in there a bunch
of BS
yeah man sugar make you more dehydrate
you're not gonna feel good man
oh you then you just sweet and and
dehydrate I'll do when I get done with a
bike ride I'm just gonna pop on these
things in a little bit of water shake it
up not be worried about it lucrative E
is available nationwide Target Whole
Foods Costco or how about to get 25% off
when you go to liquid IV com use the
code k ATS at checkout that's 25% off
anything you order when you use the
promo code k ATS at liquid IV dot-com
that's right get better hydration today
at liquid IV com promo code ka TS but
you can feel it going to your body when
you drink it I'm so jealous you can also
find them nationwide at Target Whole
Foods or Costco Oh bro
I noticed my nose hairs were trying to
make an appearance everything I do
they're trying to do the wave out my
nostril oh yeah the connector my
mustache oh yeah I've seen that man I've
seen that people had that snout stache
for this gross write out their nose oh
that's terrible no chick digs that uh-uh
she does is probably your brother yeah
you gotta actually take care of that and
what you need now is the weed whacker
it's the new manscaped product and it
goes straight in your snout man and it
keeps it tight and they tighten up your
snout bro manscape is forever changing
the grooming game with this weed whacker
it's like somebody's just bikini wax and
inside of your holes brush start living
can breathe better when you're the hairs
not all up in your nose and guess what
the battery lasts up to 90 minutes
listen if it takes you 90 minutes to cut
that hair you got bigger problems than
just your nose hairs oh hey man man and
you really get out there look fellow 79%
of partners polled admitted that long
nose hair is a major turnoff and what
bothers me about that at 79 percent not
a hundred percent yeah that's what
bothers me
yeah time to upgrade your manscaping
routine with the weed whacker get 20%
off and free shipping with the code king
sting WW that stripe sell off and free
shipping with the code King sting wwm
escape comm hey dude that's right get
them nasty freaking snout little badgers
out of your freaking holes bro tighten
up your grill tighten up your airwaves
do with that new hitter from manscape
manscape calm
code king sting w/w oh dude it's Taco
Tuesday so yeah try it and one of
Britain's four tacos tonight business
here's doughnut replace them
I called his son earlier on it on the
calculator and we're gonna divide up
some business
ready go okay your hair looks nice
always there a special occasion going on
in your life right now
no just decided to look like a lady
today
you go on any dates this weekend no I
went home and spend time with my family
though and do you have a man that you
kind of linked up with can you go back
home do you have like a um you know a
regional kind of man and your folks are
maybe an Old Faithful yeah yeah
something like that only if I go to
booty call yeah the BC Tara there was
and what there was and then he got on my
nerves
why what did he do I don't like it when
um one guy's trip on me if I'm not your
girlfriend oh yeah I don't like that you
don't need that energy yeah was a white
guy no Asian dude Wow taking that at all
thank you God more insecure as he found
out that there are more because after
last week there were a bunch of Mexican
guys who slid into my DM I got a certain
like Mexicans yes and then he started to
get very insecure about that and he
annoyed me some when I went home I just
didn't he doesn't realize what he's
dealing with the type of animal little
cat is it's at do you find do you think
you are hard to deal with as a
girlfriend cat no I'm really easy I find
that people don't like that I'm so laid
back because it makes them feel like I
don't care about them but I'm just not
the type of person to trip off someone
if you're not my boyfriend
okay like that's the way to be that's a
way to baby you know if that's true or
not I don't know
you know I almost said it that's
independent though yes cat does seem
independent I don't I think you would
eat a man up like if Chappell for
example I feel like you would we would
not see a fella I feel like I would
right when you say that though I feel
it's like ah dude how about Chappelle in
Phoenix because you'd go Chappelle me
Callan this dude to end is set does a
backflip like what the [ __ ] bro yeah
well the [ __ ] called me out cuz they
see you don't here and they didn't think
I could do it you gotta let your lines
yeah oh I know I'm gonna tell you my dad
I asked my dad's talking like that I go
dad when I get my AC T die you're 32
years oh no no friend out of 32 he's got
a 29 not impossible to believe
hey you've done a lot of things that
people say you wouldn't do bro
yeah that do constantly frickin purses
the envelope man 32 knows your buddy
all right you remember his I don't know
prayed 29 is so much all right cool
thank you later
we're we're changing stereotypes in here
can't even take cat did even go to
college
you got a twin on the a CT Chapelle look
at what's a UNC go and take the a CT or
SATs oh that's right I think you're the
only one without a degree in here they
know though you didn't get one drop down
chin does you and I are the only one
with degrees make sense chin dropped out
to tour across Asia as funny character
but I want to a bunch of colleges a ton
yeah it didn't count though yeah I went
to like three junior colleges and
transfer to Cal State University
Fullerton and then after I dropped out
because I was doing full-time computer
networking so I was making money making
a living so I just dropped out and I
can't believe even getting some type of
a gang or something cuz you got
surprised you can get recruited yeah
they're so big well I was gonna say
because you seem like you seem
multi-racial to me multiracial you
I could see you being like cream it not
mistaken for other ones like Filipino
yeah yeah you never Maxine happen
no never Mexican the magical baby right
there I could see you Mexican pill
no I could see you being Mexican easily
all right cowboy like a Mexican kind of
like Ponderosa
Nick Nick looks 100% white 100% yeah
it's like but he also looks like
Lawrence Taylor and white face bring up
LT and white face Nick doesn't is this I
wasn't personally in a game on it
you have the same nose Nick Nick I could
have said chin I could have seen washing
like the knives at night from the game
you know same nose wow I see that I have
this shitty gift man I'm like Rain Man
but I can't that's also the strangest
pitch Lawrence Taylor I don't think that
was Laura's killer they have this exact
same nose Wow
no I'm not even joking they look the
same look yeah if you took that beetle
same lips like gin yup did you play
football I was on the team so know what
it means it was accused of a crime by a
cheerleader Nick you got some brotox'
dude you would be great
I've gotten Doc Rivers from my friends
back in Wisconsin quite a bit okay
I'm feeling more Lawrence Taylor there
ooh yes I could see that write that one
yeah maybe a little
hey man we got what we got all kind of
diversity in here yeah there's a theme
building of who I look like yeah and
we're respecting a lot of the western
territory today Cheyenne Wyoming
Elena Durango Colorado Durango Durango
hats off to Santa Fe New Mexico Arizona
that's a funny we brought up look-alikes
cuz I was gonna launch a new segment
today
I'm sure I'm not the only one but I
always get tagged in like pictures
videos of people that look like
everybody on here so we'll just go
through some of the the look-alikes that
people find or post and we'll pick a
winner and maybe send them some crap I
find in the back ok my crap do you mean
your underwear
you should pal boy you got a little
sugars tank with those hip movements
yeah Izzie yeah for why my guy didn't
the Rams draft him do you know his name
is Oscar the marina Lena he did
America's audition for America's Got
Talent
Wow they say he has talent yeah anybody
can have that a man in a man with four
dogs on there and they're like oh that's
Talent oh wow
Oh big guy with sweat yes he got buns
okay boys and he seems a little so fit
mildly homoerotic as well just mildly
his legs are oh [ __ ] let me get that
sofa cushion brother but you could lose
some coins in here man yeah you can find
a couple skittles up in there
that's nice sweet and yeah boy yes a
little sugar interstate that's cool
though
yeah he's famous in Arizona he does the
choreography for like the Rattlers
dancers and I think the Cardinals
dancers I don't shadow Kliff Kingsbury -
there's no more AFL they've won
championships to work yes sure they did
Chappelle so but who else does oh he's
out of a job if he just works with her
antlers no he what is he doing Chappelle
choreography okay I'm just trying to get
to the bottom of this it's suspect well
yeah
first of all the Rattlers have to play
real snakes I say you get an eighth of
them out there you get a tree last
[ __ ] snakes out there let's see you
soon that's what I like about a lot of
these teams stealing people's name
you know like the Penguins put them real
[ __ ] penguins on ice yeah get them
[ __ ] out there huh
[ __ ] hit up you know light up a sweet
little [ __ ] dab of meth next to a
couple penguins brother see these pings
get ya and get them mice [ __ ] out
there but the CEOs ooh man I think we'll
[ __ ] bite your damn toes off one at a
time oh they're saying he looks like
Chappelle yeah you posted that video and
I got tagged so much everybody I was
Chappelle and here's someone saw Theo at
the carnival actually Jimmy Hutchins did
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Wow and the juxtaposition of
it's an eclipse it is June it's always
June 22nd
I don't know I feel like that young man
could definitely you guys could be each
other a little more cushion for the bus
around the tummy yeah he seemed like a
little softer yeah a little more Brown
yeah it's you if you can't do a back
flip yeah there we go yeah it's you if
you're into video game set of
cheerleading yeah okay and that was me
at Theo's origin story and this one
someone saw Brandon getting some work
done
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
welcome to the bomb and then I think we
got one [ __ ] boys I can't even look at
you
stuff I would like you come over and
sing that song late at night you feel me
Stefan awake you like happy I know but
we still gonna celebrate we didn't
practice it why are you whispering
that's just how I talk I got 70% of my
voice taken out
and we got one more and we got someone
saw Chappell getting some groceries this
one is probably the most sent in and
that's risky to doing a Walmart
depending what city
shop for way less you don't say yeah
praise God brother so I think we have a
clear winner for cats in the wild today
it was before I get this bottom before I
get my bottom stone open with the chance
she hooked me up with that I like how he
has them titty implants on his ass I'll
tell you right now zero presenter
shoutout Arizona man yeah shut out
Stockton shut out a shot to Germany
where Stefan yes a doubt stick got more
on the wild side with Stefan I think
yeah his beard did look drawn on mmm-hmm
oh he's been through he's been through a
lot we got to get him in here
[Laughter]
joking around by him seeing you happy
birthday they don't you want that stunt
double breath oh yeah Wiener stunt dog
unless they do a [ __ ] Brokeback
Mountain to I don't think he's gonna get
the part if you do whatever man I've
been watching hey dude reruns all
alright god bless yo man huh moving on
to some debate club CEO Brendan got a
debate club for you last night just got
done watching that old Brian Cowen claim
to fame hitter the Joker
on the big Batman fan I like the Dark
Knight so question is who's the better
Joker
Joaquin Phoenix or Heath Ledger let me
know Gang Gang bat butts ah man I don't
like it I've said it like we're
comic-book movies are going it's too
realistic I don't that Joker great movie
that's it was so dark man yeah I like
that Jack Nicholson Joker I like when
it's a little pretend it's doing real mm
I don't need Batman being all realistic
you know I like it fake I like mr.
freeze
chill out I like Jim Carrey is the
Riddler I'm saying thank you I gained a
video as the penguin yeah the best yes
Michelle Pfeiffer's Catwoman yeah yeah I
couldn't pretend Lynn the shit's too
real man I'll tell you what this is a
pop weapon y'all can suck my Stephan
dick like I like Jared Leto as the Joker
I thought he was dope as the Joker I
haven't seen many of this do you see the
max oh I saw the Joaquin Phoenix now I
thought it was amazing it's so it's a
mascot it was super smart the way that
they like went into the Joker was more
actually but yeah I guess if you're I'm
not a big fan of this type of stuff
where people you know change their
clothes and be like uh somebody who can
do all kind of amazing stuff all of a
sudden like but I like Batman being a
little more unrealistic like because
Batman doesn't really have any
skills just a rich right to fight right
and I pay some Morgan Freeman and make
all these ante [ __ ] he's basically aunty
[Laughter]
he's the original before it went real
dog they went wait yeah but I like I
thought the I haven't seen the Heath
Ledger 1 you've never seen is he good so
good but he but he's barely in it like
he's in it but he's not that much in it
compared to Joaquin Phoenix who carried
the whole movie he was in a more than
Jared Leto and Suicide Squad though
here's a problem that Jared Leto said
how much he was in they could have they
could have made a whole movie just on
him is the Joker but they use piss they
did it so much he's barely in it
shipping it way more and he died though
in it right no he didn't die believe
shooting it no no and who's the guy in
the lower middle that guy who is that
that's Stefan that's jared leto oh it is
I haven't seen that one a lot of people
confuse it with Tony Hinchcliffe - Jack
Nicholson wasn't bad either Tony just go
floki antifa as well Wow no probably
more of a Stefan vibe there than Joker
yeah you've never seen Dark Knight don't
do that's literally my favorite movie oh
really it's amazing I love to watch it I
played the video game video games not
that great okay it's cool that's a video
game yeah Dark Knight's amazing yeah I
got to watch it then but I thought the
new Joker was good but I I was heavy
though it was heavy oh it's real heavy
man and Brian was in it for three
seconds yeah but I thought he had a good
little idea I thought he did a good job
in it did you think I mean he was like
hey and then they just kind of went on
you know yeah I was here to talk to him
more I wish they would have talked to
about when the man was shooting that I
was in New York shooting some something
for Bravo TV on watch what happens live
with Andy Cohen so he was shooting Joker
then and I was like oh dude and we were
literally where he was and where I was
where I'm in a block away goes meet me
for dinner so I could have been for
dinner and you know the little [ __ ]
in the movie there's
I get their behinds at dinner with the
[ __ ] with the small man to even tell
me no Joe hey oh and you just let me
goes be cool be cool I'm cool but should
give me a heads up dude
yeah great guy though great guy
yeah wonderful best man right there look
and what's his name's Harold Harold
literally the worst part about this is
someone else just like in Brendan's out
of his mind someone has it saved as
[ __ ] from Joker Lake yo-yo yeah you
know a lot of Scottish people are have
this syndrome really yep why is that I
think it's just through they rebellious
mmm-hmm
it's like I'm not being told [ __ ] you
you know it makes sense like it's at a
molecular level man do you think all the
small people hate on the guy from games
are thrown because he's kind of like
their Lord and Savior you know I'm
saying like he takes if you're gonna get
a role he's gonna get it like he can
only have so many small people in a
movie you're gonna have the dude from
Game of Thrones yeah you know it swears
he has kids and his daughter's normal
size so like holding a handstand she's
[ __ ] six foot tall that's wild man
crazy yeah they used to have a man bus
who was a mechanic and he was married to
a little person and everybody was
shocked we didn't know no one had ever
seen it before because you're not really
allowed to say we would refer to him as
midgets you know you did twice but
[ __ ] is also a French word if you go
to France stay in America a whole life
dude yeah get out there who do a
backflip in the [ __ ] Eiffel Tower
it's a mess car go and do a cartwheel
bro I've only been I've only been in
Canada in Mexico oh yeah you got to get
out Taiwan go to Jamaica brah quit
[ __ ] around dude go to go to go to
the [ __ ] Thailand go to one of the
suck bars yeah I would
Oh a suck bar well you get a nice cold
beer and get sucked off under the table
oh hey 2574 who they hire have old duels
for this and you could fake the funk no
you can just get a beard
they don't drink it look here fro ders
dude that is the worst idea to go all
the way somewhere just to get sucked off
for a nickel somewhere bro go see a site
and do something but also go to the Sun
go to a tombstone or something you know
go do something special man you go to
see Allen see Bruce Lee's grave hey you
got I've seen you go to Amsterdam see oh
you could see Jim Morrison's grave dude
I did like that about the Batman when he
was in like the underground cave and he
had the old man who was helping him out
which one was that Alfred Alfred yeah I
like that one
was that an Amsterdam no no that what
I'm not sure what movie that was who was
in it that was like hey dark shadows or
what's the cup the first Batman I mean
the Batcave and Alfred were in every
Batman but Michael you know would be the
shittiest Batman ever would be Tom
Arnold horrible to watch who's the worst
Batman Val Kilmer No oh that's your boy
I like to see those are my feet back man
returns although those are my Batman
yeah this new [ __ ] did Ben Affleck play
him okay have Ben Affleck played him
that one kind of went under the Rutgers
bat member of Superman's dad Ben Affleck
was that juicy babbling was he he's
Batman on them and that deck of D ball
Batman Oh Dan yeah he got real juicy
might have to get a sack of that yeah
the best one was the animated series yes
the car it was like more serious was the
best it was like mid-90s it was really
dark kind of serious it was awesome yes
that thing gets what I saw mmm honestly
when you said it that's the one I
thought you the bald Alfred that guy was
cool what's an Alfred Morgan Freeman and
one of them yeah no no that was a Lucius
Fox in Dark Knight
he was like my favorite movie Dark
Knight Michael Caine was Alfred in
darkness was good Mark Hamill as Joker
was amazing - Mark Hamill was not the
swimmer original uh he was the one who
did the animated series oh yeah he did
right now it's time for a real we also a
stamp for a black Batman I feel like you
know I'll do it then we're gonna do
black spider-man Donald Glover is gonna
be spider-man really yeah come on they
were like now we don't a black
spider-man but then they did the what's
name not my rice who's the kid - Miles
Morales a diverse spider-verse which is
the best the best and the second ones
coming out next year
and is it animated yeah it's animated
it's in but it's so good though me my
son went to the theater seven times the
one oh wow I know and we bought the
spider-man shoes Oh some spider-man join
ones all that he wore in spider purse
giddy up man is giddy up here we go what
else got Nick another debate club
beautiful young man huh well it's by far
the best Batman spider-man oh yeah I got
you
well Sophie's your boy Logan from the
30180 damn it's your boy Larry from
Compton out of Louisiana that debate
club for y'all what's up Larry what is
the real LA the boo or Los Angeles tell
us what you've done Angeles Gang Gang
Deez Nuts so he's saying Los Angeles on
Louisiana what's the real LA you know
who's from LA though you know I'm saying
yeah Wayne who's from LA no one's really
from Louisiana but also people Louisiana
get the [ __ ] out as well and they come
down Lee mm-hmm mm-hmm
and lays in a tough time right now I'm
hating on LA right now just cuz it's
there's bombs everywhere there's
protesters looting we got the gas
governor in the world Gavin well first
of all what do you get it for you were
like a man named Gavin
you didn't showing Gavin you're gonna
have problem Gavin is your buddy who
plays baseball it's his little brother
that's over on the side of the field
[ __ ] sneaking snow cones and doing
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] oh that's Gavin yeah
the guy who steals money from you you
know I'm saying like that's a weird name
yeah I think I mean la proper is it's
just Hollywood and [ __ ] is the part of
LA that I forget sometimes I'm gonna les
I just don't like the Hollywood she does
not thinking the things that [ __ ]
everything up cuz you go on like other
podcasts you go on like JK news or
something and though those people it's
all they're just normal they sound like
the same things that we think about you
know yeah like it's just
JK knew that's a new site it's some
podcast right you guys know JK just
kidding news ya know it's like a YouTube
channel with a bunch of Asians and
Mexicans it's hilarious dude and yeah
it's just like they're just like regular
normal yeah it's just not like Hollywood
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] but I feel the soul as
being that video like we're working on
we're not staying quiet anymore yeah and
they look quiet and also I assume
everyone that videos racist
dude I'll [ __ ] somebody's it throw a
harpoon through our window
and we could probably actually that
could get to get in trouble for saying
that
I think la the sub non non Hollywood la
is great Louisiana
we're just on fire right now yeah and
Louisiana to also a lot of it is
Canadians that they sent down there you
know yeah a lot of Canadian criminals
they sent down to Louisiana into the
Acadian areas and stuff like that
Louisiana is that Trueblood hitter
though yeah so I always write Louisiana
so you got a lot of bootleg Canucks down
there hide and doing Canadian [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] dirty war but Louisiana
Ellen came from there who's a cut so
that's against you guys yeah so we got a
negative one hmm but what else came out
Louisiana Purchase first of all you're
welcome
about 17 states yellow us this was a all
these [ __ ] this is a parody that Kyle
Dunnigan did who is [ __ ] hilarious
it's amazing can we watch it yeah I'm on
the fence about it I take responsibility
for every unchecked moment for every
time I said give me five on the light
hand side I'll take responsibility for
not listening to Megan and and leaving
me knickers on the floor they're called
Underpants I will no longer allow an
unchecked moment I was no longer throw
away the african-american part of the
oil cookie just to get to the creamy
white middle I will hire more black
hookers for a job should not be a death
sentence sleeping in your own home
should not be a death sentence sorry I
guess no longer bystanders well who the
hell's that broad racist murderous cops
need neat line only time is gonna stop
the perpetrators
to account struck 20 min juice he killed
somebody it's Bill Martin precious yeah
that's holy man I'm gonna say Louisiana
does that problem bomb dude so yeah you
have to yeah the time was Canadians and
Mexicans my family's Mexican I went with
Canadians I'll never live that oh yes
[Music]
look from the club to this crazy dude
yeah man he's at Gymboree and he's
[ __ ] dropping all these yeah I go
Louisiana man I'll stick with the boot
man and here's a couple of young men who
are obviously getting lonely this guy
took his own take on relationship advice
career advice I need a little bit of
advice it's not relationship advice like
you usually do I need some career advice
I'm a wrestler with AWA in Maryland and
I don't have a finisher yet so uh help
me out if you will
gang and he's the Chesapeake Crippler
sounds like a serial killer
fad mystic Rick and that Swiss
wheelchair brother I'll tell you you
could do that anytime you see what's
it's the name is fish a movie just
doesn't have one yeah I think name it
any ideas
weapons I don't know how about you douse
them in honey
oh sweet tooth killer oh yeah put him in
the sweet tooth dude then you get out
the jar honey right now no comes out the
[Laughter]
music kid you don't see him pug become
our Undertaker but does song hits and
it's fine Stefan it goes boys boys you
can flying in short George here's what I
think
first of all excuse me Kelly arrows oh
you need to get a you and another fella
need to come out of the closet and get a
gay tag team first ever right yes and
you hold him kind of bent over the other
guy jumps off the top rope hits him
right in the butt with his cry and uh
and just puts that booty to sleep you
know it's called the bottom it's called
the Foggy Bottom
not the flying bottom so that's what I
think you do you do you get them like a
confused have them bent over in the
middle of the ring you go up the top
rope you fly off D first and hit them
right in the butt yeah and the guy
getting hit in the butts going no not
the butt yeah what song with the duo
come out to open the door baby it's cold
outside
maybe that one is too slow so really
can't stay baby it's cold outside
oh I know which one laughs to the left
how whose birthday is it super short
shorts ass cheetah back well or you put
them in the and your other finished
movies called that dirty birthday bro
yeah and that's when you lay them on the
ground you put that you open their mouth
up their unconscious you jump off the
top rope Weiner yeah it's called the
broke bag yeah when they're already
asleep and you hit them with that D bro
good I think you got you got some great
ideas good start
yeah jumping-off point why be a
heterosexual arrest or do that [ __ ] is
so 1800s and that WWE fan base I Love
You Man bro you come out as the first
gay wrestler yeah but you got to get
real tan like razor ramon and get all
oiled up and some short shorts they
always go crazy man crazy amount of oil
bro I'm talking even putting Vaseline on
your tongue everything yes y'all full
out full out just wet wet seal got it go
there I am in the background of this how
did I get in there and who is this Nancy
Pelosi this is [ __ ] unbelievable
[Laughter]
[ __ ] has to stop man think think Razor
Ramon but the touch of West Hollywood
just really really outlandish yeah yeah
gays are on yeah the gay Ramon your fish
is the power bottom yeah and you just
hit him with that bottom dude you got
them bent over and you should hit them
straight up Dee first room you're
welcome yeah you're welcome
Tressa Pete Crippler aw may or w AE what
is it called
IEW United Arab Emirates mm-hmm
fighting yeah quit fightin as a straight
male that shit's it's old-school man
yeah be originally not gay just figure
it out yeah get gay in the ring man yeah
why be yeah rachel maddow I think the
ultimate warrior - such off back in the
day yeah whose birthday it's a great
song unless the managers trying to
molest you all the time while you're
singing it here we got a guy springfield
wrestling let's get into this Jim went
out of uh Springfield Illinois and Ted
yeah but we could have we're wrestlers
close out with some king KR stands
what's up guys Marc from Massachusetts
last week a place last place in the
talent competition this week I got a
king under sting it for you guys what do
you guys think about scars that
standard-issue scar tissue of the scar
from brain surgery at a brain tumor
removed a couple years back Brendan and
I got that cauliflower from wrastlin had
it drained a couple times but it just
keeps coming back so uh showing off your
scars King under stinging getting a buzz
buzz dude first of all thanks for
sending something in not getting a
victory and coming back hard with this
second hitter right yeah dude tattoos
are the Lord you know the Lord your
tattoo artist when you get tattoos
that's up to the big man upstairs when
you get scars you mean yeah that's true
loss the way to go there all of them are
original you have any scars my friend
got bit by a shark
we knew that close to somebody who's
been [ __ ] snagged on Grayson have it
I mean I know him well enough to call
him and get it on FaceTime any time so
actually oh you have no powers away
actually so I didn't do that yeah let me
guess you got bit by the shark and then
probably got on some morphine for the
pain
yeah then it led to pills yeah that's
exactly what happened to us that long
game great white yep
god I forgot yeah that's crazy you do
that man yeah you're like the drug
whisperer dude you're like lamb
yes you don't have no scars though the
some guys sitting there shooting up he's
just like to tell me everything you got
an a mild fender bender I bought a bunch
of coins and always young and had to get
him taken out of my body
yep and then win him right through here
and then what else happened
not much I got that earthworm jim hit
her here knocked the dude out then they
had to put plates in my hand
did you really pound fracture why would
you what party Hindu you hit him with
[ __ ] no-nonsense Keith was too late
to the game so I punched him and at the
time is some low-level league in
Virginia like yeah we can't pay for that
greenly pay for it myself you to pay for
the guy not to pay for the surgery mess
Oh Danny of it meanwhile still wandering
around north was Johnny Curtis really
happy yeah I knew it was bad work too
cuz it's a huge scar my thumb's not
great and I go how'd it go he goes I did
my best
the doctor yeah I did my best
right on you know get some weird guys
give me scars cat um just one on my
pinky that's it I cut myself trying to
cook a sweet potato and I shouldn't got
stitches but I just put a bandaid on it
for two weeks
Melanie skirts Pomeranian that makes
sense chin any scars yeah and then what
I got a few but this is the biggest one
Oh what was that one from on your hand I
kind of fight with a Vietnamese gang
yeah people there
people huh my uncle says sorry it's okay
it's been a long time they hit you over
the head with something
you know those Maglites mob shoes
someone snuck in during the fight and
then smack me around the head did it
knock you out he knocked out but I just
I felt like I just insulate wasn't a
dream
did it feel it felt warm right dude it
was like water hose of blood going down
my arm so that was warm and then I just
felt like I was like and it kind of
feels high yeah I felt felt like I was
in a dream good someone sat on my car so
that sounds like what the [ __ ] and then
I realized oh [ __ ] he's a gang member
and his whole gang came out with bats
also they have bats clubs and it was
just you by yourself my other friends
everywhere are you sure this sounds like
an episode of uh this sounds like this
fast and furious Tokyo do back in those
days oh it sounds like Bad News Bears
import cars yeah drivers Nick in these
cars
I had appendix taken out middle school
and one time I was snowboarding just in
the backyard of my friends and the
snowboard came up and hit me in the head
I'm not really snowboarding kind of just
hanging out on the board yeah it's just
fallen basically but like flight I use
that appendicitis scar years later when
I was working at Sports Authority
because I wanted to go to a music
festival and I just kind of like red
ended up and I put bandages on him and I
just like dink all in and I was like I
had appendicitis and I showed him the
scar and it was it looked fresh move
sound set in Minneapolis saw Mac Miller
it was awesome
Wow really poor he died huh yeah it was
the it was like 2013 but best live
performer I've ever seen he's been our
shows too so that's hurts to hear that
[ __ ]
fentanyl got him huh fentanyl fentanyl
we got be shoppers Johnny Curtis
oh yeah I'll tell you where I break my
this is oh this is 12 years ago
is it really sin what uses in Fairfax
Virginia right next to Washington DC
your knockouts about to happen yes yep
this is why I broke my hand and I got
Saabs I got set up let me let me set up
the fight so I had one fight and then
they go hey do you want to find out of
town
sure you go we get this guy he has some
wrestling and I go okay cuz I was in a
wrestler and I was like it's only my
second fight I wanna fight a really good
wrestle you
he's just a high school wrestler on the
right we get there and we're all waiting
to get in the hotel and this guy comes
in on this huge Harley and has a big
American flag and was like Jesus Christ
who was this and the guy goes that's
Johnny Curtis I mean who the [ __ ] Johnny
Curtis he goes he's a wrestling coach at
George Mason Ford four-time all-american
Wow play rest on the national team I'm
like [ __ ] that's my opponent like that's
him damn so I was really upset I just
wanna let you know there's a reason why
him sorry I'm really upset now this poor
guy
it's his hometown his home college and I
not only did I knock him out with the
left hook but his knee blew out he
towards a CR o and then yeah so good
play they probably paid for him I bet
hometown hero did that land or not cause
that's gonna promise to come today oh
[ __ ] boom knee blew out that's where I
broke my thumb
now look what I do I'm mad but look I
almost blew my knee out here watch this
are they booing use it was that some
some lot lizard right here watch this
all spoil my knee out watch that was
your [ __ ] Chevelle bird I always do
showing off that [ __ ] bird boy oh
that's gonna happen here white and jump
a lot I was so upset they tried it they
tried hustling your boy
they tried Sam back [ __ ] bruh I'd say
he's a really nice guy was he yeah
afterwards y'all friends now nah but
then we didn't realize my hand was that
[ __ ] up we knew we could see like
bones protruding out but it was like
yeah well you'll be all right my dad's
like I've never been to DC let's go see
all the cool [ __ ] so I'm like walking
around all day lightheaded my hands
getting bigger
what did you know I knew I [ __ ] it up
we didn't realize how bad but your
gentleman was just going because you
just won and it's awesome real upset
DC's awesome huh the best they got a
great for comedy the best comedy tell
you choose special there DC improv yeah
lit this [ __ ] don't good food good some
of the food in the West weird went down
a Johnny Curtis highlight man's good I
like man that's crazy
I appreciate anybody's to do that it's
so while watching I don't know what does
happening there
not a lot of options fellas does this
seem like a different person could you
get back in there right now and do that
again you think I'm more skilled than
that kid was yeah yeah
I also made 1,400 bucks doing that oh
and then at my surgery cost 2300
lost money fighting that guy look what
you right now yeah I get a rematch sure
Johnny
I want a rematch for me Oh word I'd love
to see you and Johnny go at it although
he can wrestle right that'd be a good
match probably huh
think so would you go out there and
fight him yeah not raining you do this
is the training right now oh right here
yeah or a street fight us discussing it
yeah I do it I would better bro it'd be
crazy well I've always bet on you man oh
I'll be your cheerleader man I'll be in
there in the corner oh [ __ ]
yeah it was tough on me but he's already
he's coming to be a cheerleader
you don't tell Stephan what to do
clearly don't know Stefan bra Stephan
your house on a plane now yeah okay what
he looks up man Stefan's gonna see this
tomorrow morning Germany Blake what the
hell he looks like a cross between you
and Peter Manfredo jr. you know who
Peter Manfredo jr. is the pride of
Providence yeah the pride of Providence
bring up Peter Montgomery cheeks lifted
do when you find stuff on Instagram this
is Karen after a surgery he probably bro
you should get tell them save his
eyelids and you get them injected
somewhere it's not a bad idea
bro that'd be so crazy dude in from town
they they gotta take lipo out of cow
[ __ ] if I take lie pal counts
tubby input it looks like Brennan and
Peter from an Fredo junior mm Fredo jr.
though didn't have surgery on the nose
that's years of boxing do you remember
Peter my friend jr. from The Contender
I do I was a such a fan and he fought
that dude this Sergio the surgery of the
snake Maura
oh great Martin show and she chose a
monster that job made me cry the way
they built it up and it was the fight
cinematic Emily and the kids yes
show god I was a good she was like
boxing's version of alternate fighter
britain right more well done it was like
more cinematic to be like even the way
they shot the fights it look like a
budget yeah they did a good job with
those fights but then you had sugar rain
you know what he was talking about it's
a vessel rate always made about himself
yeah yeah yeah oh god that was a good
show man yeah thousand two thousand son
followed man afraid it for a while after
that online he just I don't think you
ever really got it on track and then he
I think you were tired
the Sergio still fight no it's been too
long
huh no there's no way sir Jim Morris
commentator now for de zon he is yeah
2018 last time he fought he lost Daniel
Jacobs which is Jacobs a monster he is
yes Wow he went to a draw with Sugar
Shane Mosley man sure they lost a Birnam
forest nothing they beat Vernon foresees
a lot of good wins Peter Manfredo jr. he
beat him twice mmm last fight was to
1816 Wow
yeah he's retired now huh damn you lost
to who though shabbos jr. well hopefully
they can train me on my boxing you know
what Johnny Curtis is that his name how
old is he
but here's what I think you're okay
hello and I thought it was 40 or like
late thirties now you're fighting a 50
year old man yeah you're gonna fight I
want to fight a 50 year old man well if
you want to open up for Brendan in that
area you wanna fighting the night before
which is gonna go tell you sell 400
seats up Johnny Curtis
[Laughter]
with that he's actually 50 years old
right now oh yeah - so he's 38 when I
find him Wow damn say you got a shot
yeah they tried honey honey dog in your
boy I don't think so if he's wanting to
fight you can fight him he's experienced
yeah he's making a choice man yeah he's
gonna take the angry out towards Brennan
if he if he has any on you yeah
you're basically a your voodoo doll
you're gonna be a visual that could be a
wrestling name voodoo doll that isn't a
name and you put a pan in him at the end
yeah what is this what's going on here
this is obviously Pramod and uh we're
gonna close it out with one last King
under sting it's the Leo Brandon king of
the sting
high school sweethearts getting married
Oh bang bang bust nuts wrote your
wedding night a little more classy
around the broad bro look at the how old
is this kid high school sweethearts and
then they're sixteen yeah young [ __ ]
it's a good question man you know
there's times where I feel like I wish I
would have gotten married when I was in
high school or something uh especially
these days doesn't really work out cuz
think out they wouldn't think how much
of a dumb ass you were at sixteen you
grow so even now think four years ago
you grow so much a different person then
I guess hopefully you guys grow together
major and different [ __ ] I was in a
transformers on 16 I'm gonna [ __ ] about
transformers now you feel me mm-hmm I
like I did only black girls when I was
16 yeah I would still do it now yeah
matters man well you know high school
sweethearts is tough man would you do
what Chapelle would you've gone back to
high school and got married your high
school sweetheart my first girlfriend
was [ __ ] two years oh yeah great
going great man what do they call it
once your first girlfriend get married
when you're [ __ ] 2013 why didn't you
ever have a girlfriend before that's a
reservoir anger bro he did in 1.0 you
know that's a red flag though you know
but think of peanuts you dress like but
think about if when you got married when
you had all those anger issues you're
different person now I'll be right you
have to work on your Li you have to work
on yourself breathe obviously save it's
best that I never was in a relationship
cuz I was yeah I was just so crazy you
know hey Kat you dated homeboy for never
yeah damn near 10 years from high school
yeah I was with him from the time I was
14 until I was 24 and three we got
married just be bored you just at one
point you just friends yes
at one point your friends your roommate
mm-hmm-hmm but if you like a good friend
then that's where it kind of falls off
you know I think that's fine if you guys
are just like good friends at that point
I think a lot of marriages kind of end
up that way anyways yeah if you felt
like a good friend then you can get
married oh yeah it's interesting you
know if you'd have gone back in time
chan what would happen if he got married
your high school girlfriend that little
one that was on your lap and your
300-pound Labradoodle I don't know I do
be remember having like a really big
crush and she was course it was it was
really that could be your wrestling name
big crush and you just drink orange soda
on the side but I'm glad I didn't
actually hook up with some of the
crushes because like I got to be friends
with afterwards and realize oh well we
were not really made for each other
amen yeah so yeah no I wouldn't not high
school
Nick nah man I talked about I peaked in
middle school a lot long dry spell in
high school so there there was no
sweethearts I had a great high school I
just wasn't getting it sound sad you're
snowboarding in your backyard I remember
it fondly call it a week before
graduation damn right I forgot that no
any secretly records I can go back and
watch the video later
hopefully one of us smelled a like oh
look this is where they find my
underwear I'm super industry she rubs
her feet on it so I can sell this [ __ ]
cinesín or underwear did you told me she
was gonna send in the update and then
she said she would and I haven't seen it
you talking about you talking about
streaks yes streaks my thanks are us
yeah where did she come up with a name
uh I think the default has become
streaks even though we all ripped out
[Laughter]
Taco Tuesday tonight at Brendan yeah all
right I'll be there a member what time
don't have my girl Miguel these [ __ ]
talk cuz they're not show up sevenish
707 okay don't be laughing out loud
waking up my kids though you know I do
yeah actually don't the great laugh yeah
it's a great laugh but just laughing
your car for you yep if your sings you
want to talk about is write down a card
just text yours your ideas okay I got
well good to be back man alright
vo got cheeks and brand started streaks
stay big boy bike club ain't no wet get
you one of those gray black hitters
[Music]
security and a limousine service built
only for tweens and feel looks like
lifts weights at a truck stop
[ __ ] eatin and Wisconsin cheese cats
bringing those [ __ ] boys to their knees
Jim's wearing a mask Hales playing hacky
in the Sun Brenda can't name desserts or
cheese or TV shows got that CTE and
feels head lips ain't nothin just
Louisiana or screamin out there gang we
go to hell
bus lanes you got sheets in Britain
starts reach think boy bike club ain't
nowhere one of those green black hitters
[Music]
gang gang those naughty boys